first speaker of the night is
max gendler and i'm hoping i pronounced
that right the last name
uh what's exciting about max is he works
for the new york times he has a
background and
a little more on the technical end of
the spectrum and is now moving more and
more towards policy
just like the rest of the industry i
might say um so
i'm very curious uh on what he wants to
discuss with everyone here and uh if uh
correct me if i'm wrong max but the way
you wanted to do this a little bit more
in the discussion format right
so we have two main questions that you
want to um
explore um would you also be open for
questions from the audience
yes absolutely i think at any point that
anyone from the audience would like to
ask a question
i'm sure we can field it uh i think
uh discussion especially in half an hour
is the best way to do this because
data ethics is is a massive subject that
it absolutely cannot be covered in a
half hour so hopefully
this can be more of like an illuminating
discussion
along lines of just peeling back a layer
and letting people see inside a little
cool so
um we've prepared two questions that are
going to be the main focus of today's
topic and
the first question is you know you work
at the new york times so you have a bit
of an overview of what scale might be
like i don't know exactly but i believe
the new york times is definitely one of
the more popular
newspapers media outlets in the united
states so
what does uh what does it mean to think
about ethics at scale what is your
perspective on that
so one of the things that we have to
think about
a lot when when we're just naturally in
the world is how we interact with people
right
and when you look at sort of the the
textbook definition of ethics a lot of
the conversations rely around your duty
to your fellow man or how you interact
what's what are you doing and how does
that affect other people
when we work in technology a lot of the
times we are separated from the people
that we're
actually affecting and they're separated
from us
there's a lot of things that are not
necessarily obvious to someone
in a situation of how they're
interacting with their technology and
what's happening
to their information while it's
happening one of the best
sort of examples that we use
of how this gets obfuscated is
if if you have someone in your home
right and you've invited them in
anything you do isn't private right
because you've invited someone into your
space
but if someone's standing outside your
window and looking inside
that's a violation of your privacy in
the case of
technology it can be very hard for
people to understand that when they're
using technology
that they are inviting outside actors
into their
home in a lot of ways that that they
possibly would feel violent their
privacy would be violated
so ethics at scale means understanding
that your user is not always aware of
what's happening
and that you have to be uh proactive
in in how you think about their privacy
and setting
up your systems for success if i were to
translate that to sort of
active empathy would you agree with that
notion
active and that's that's a good way to
think of it for sure i think
i mean one of the things that again when
you obfuscu
obfuscate someone on the internet i'm
sure we've all done this in forums right
where you're talking to someone and
they're disagreeing with you and the
and the conversation can just escalate
and escalate it's usually because you're
not putting
a face to the person or you're not
having a normal conversation with a
human
having that sort of idea of i need to
empathize with the people i'm
interacting with even though i don't
know exactly who they are or how this
affects them is a very good way of
thinking about it for sure
and and would you say that that's uh
because in tech we are a little bit more
distance from
the end users that that's harder to do
or is it like a
more of a tech problem in your
perspective
i think it's a problem that that can
manifest itself in a lot of different
ways but tech
uh is is obviously no different from the
rest of the world where we're all humans
right at the end of the day no matter
how much we try to outsource our jobs to
uh algorithms we they are created by
humans
uh their biases that are inherent in
humans are able to make their way into
algorithms they're able to make their
way into the way we set up our systems
so it i wouldn't go so far as to say
we're
more uh likely to to run into these
problems in tech but it is one of those
things that
everyone should be conscious of as as
you're working
so well what i can imagine at least i'm
i'm going to paraphrase here and the
team that i'm
talking about doesn't exist i just like
to make sure that that's clear
but let's say there's a team and there's
a data team and let's say the data team
ah they have to do recommender stuff for
let's say some company that sells some
sort of product
and i can imagine that the person who's
investing at that point in time in that
team in that project
they want to see a return on investment
so quite quickly you get this
interesting dimensionality reduction to
whatever you're doing it's a single
number we have to optimize that
and i can imagine in such a situation
it's hard to bring up this topic of
empathy
um even though if i think about it from
a risk perspective
it is actually quite interesting to
think about it that way um
i i don't know if this sort of thing
happens a lot at the new york times but
i am curious
do you have any advice for these sorts
of teams and how to maybe approach this
yes that that's a wonderful question
because i think it uh
more or less relates to 90 of the kind
of work i do
which is the the
space of data governance is in a lot of
ways
the role of translating between data
science pure tech people
and business stakeholders right it's
this understanding that there are
business people
who are maybe very well intentioned but
don't speak the language of data science
and there are data science and tech
people who are very well intentioned but
don't speak the language of business
right
so the first thing whenever you come
to someone and they're saying this is
the objective this is the only objective
first you have to understand why that's
the objective and the case that you
brought up right
the business can have a final revenue
goal they might have
uh just uh share
get our stock up we need a market yeah
all of that right
but what you also mentioned in that
question risk
is perfect because you can counter
balance this idea of
make as much money as possible now with
this idea of long-term
what is our business what are we
thinking of how are we going to move
forward forever because
you can get 50 today and never make
another buck in your life
that's not really that great but if you
tell someone we can make 40 bucks today
and 20 bucks tomorrow and 20 bucks the
day after and 20 bucks the day after
and explain to them there are actually a
lot of reasons that
privacy and ethics and and this idea of
thinking about your users and what's
good for them can pay dividends in the
fact that users do
to some extent understand when a company
is being trustworthy when a company is
dealing with them properly
and it's not always explicit it's not
always something that they
can necessarily you know
formulate out loud but but there are
feelings of trust and privacy that do
play into
the average consumer's uh thought
process whether it's
your news organization which should
obviously build itself almost entirely
on trust
to maybe a cloud service provider like
aws
or google right we also all think about
how much we trust these systems
to treat us fairly whether or not we
actively put that to paper
i can i can also imagine so i think
it's nice to be able to say okay let's
keep risk in mind whenever you're having
that conversation right if you're if
you're setting a team up etc
are you maybe also aware uh of like
projects where they really started to
emphasize uh like the empathy and like
making sure that we
have the checklist up in order do you
know of any
industry stories that you can share
where hey that was actually a good thing
we've made that investment
these stories are just getting out is my
impression
yeah so i think one of the things that
ends up happening
uh is a lot of these efforts
get wrapped under company secrecy right
they get
wrapped under this idea that we have to
keep our strategy
under wraps so there's only ever a few
things that come
out at a time but i can share something
from the new york times
that i was involved in a few years ago
so
at the time i was within the advertising
analytics group and we were
starting to come up with projects with
data governance involvement
about how do we advertise to our users
in a more ethical privacy forward way
and the first project we started was a
contextual targeting project called
project feels
in that project what we were doing is
using some survey data that we gathered
off-site about how people
reacted to headlines and summaries of
our articles
we attempted to model how any of our
articles
might make a reader feel
to some extent right we're not saying a
hundred percent of the time a reader is
going to feel this way
but we're trying to get indicators of
these articles about weddings are making
people feel happy right that's a very
obvious conclusion
but you know these are the kinds of
things that can sometimes come out of
models
so obviously there was yeah so out of
curiosity so the
could i i can assume there was some sort
of survey done perhaps off-site
because you mentioned it was outside uh
where like people literally
looked at people's emotions as they were
reading certain pieces then
what gave you a data set and this was
the basis of your work this is accurate
right
yes and i can also share a few
presentations that our data science team
has done about this
over the past few years in the in the
discord afterwards because i do think
it's a very good case study of how to
create a model that is meant to preserve
privacy for the user
um okay now so that that was the the
other direction i was also thinking
about but um
but do go on because i think this is
interesting yeah um
so but the point being is at the end of
the day right once this model is created
you have
for every article in the new york times
a
list of associated emotions some might
have no emotions some might have
multiple right
anywhere in between right those emotions
then were used
as contextual targeting for advertising
so an advertiser could come to us and
say i want to place my ad
on pages that you've classified as happy
or love or sad or inspired right
all of these then take the
advertising revenue that we would have
gotten from
behavioral targeting third-party data
any sort of
things that are less privacy preserving
and started slowly moving that towards
privacy preserving advertising and at
first
companies are skeptical right you you
need time for a new product
to be proven out you get one or two
major players to
use this advertising product you have to
take time to make sure the case studies
look good you have to make sure that
you're actually getting good information
there's negotiations happening in the
background of this i'm assuming because
some people buy in the ads and they want
to know they get their return on
investment so it's not just technical
also sales people are involved here i
suppose
yes i mean it's a it's a full it's it's
across the whole
organization right so in in terms of
who's involved there's
data science data engineers obviously
for pipelining
data analysts that would have been me at
the time
[Music]
just keeping track of how the campaigns
themselves are doing
you need ad tech people on the ground to
make sure that that the
models are probably integrating into the
ad tech stack you need
ad product team members who are going to
make sure that the ad sales teams are
properly
informed about what they're selling and
how it works and to jump onto calls if
there's questions
sometimes i would jump onto calls if
there were very serious questions
um and you need buy-in across the entire
advertising work to even go ahead right
because you need
resources in order to fund the creation
of the models in the first place
so exactly this is not a proof of
concept we're talking about but that's
getting clearer and clearer this is a
pretty big undertaking this one
yes and so in in terms of
how you how we got that initially
up to up to being one of our more
successful products is first you talk to
a few premium clients ones that you know
from the past have been
interested in experimenting with
different advertising formats
you talk to them and you might say hey
here's a new format
we know your regular ad buy for the
fourth quarter is coming through
why don't we throw in 200 000
impressions
on this new topic this new project that
we've got
and you can tell us if you like it it's
no cost to you we'll do it it's just a
bonus on top of your
usual vibe then
we'll give them a presentation at the
end of it
your regular advertising did this kind
of return on investment
this advertising that we threw in for
free even if you had paid for it
made this return on investment that sort
of comparison helps you
shift the perspective that less
information about a user
is necessarily worse right because
advertisers especially
have have been in an industry that for
so long has said
we need to know everything about a user
in order to
properly micro target and make sure that
we're getting every last penny
back in returns and
that's just not necessarily the case
there's it's not saying that
any approach that doesn't use micro
targeting will work that's
obviously not the truth you can't just
blindly uh paste
advertisements across the web and hope
it'll work but
slowly changing the narrative from none
of this works
to well this product works and now we're
developing
the next product and the next product
and constantly trying to make sure that
we're
both catering to what advertisers want
as well as making sure that our users
are protected
from invasive data privacy and this
particular
so i uh have you you might have heard of
vicky boyce it's a data science blogger
someone i'm a pretty big fan of and one
thing that this reminds me of i can also
imagine
that in order to do this new kind of
advertising that's a little bit more
safe on the privacy spectrum
you're probably going to require way
less data to handle and keep around as
well
so there's also logistical benefits in
this particular case i can't imagine if
there's less data you need
there's a there's an upside to that as
well yes i think
that to us in terms of just the the cost
of storage we we run
on um mostly google systems
so google bigquery and and google cloud
store
so in terms of the cost on our logs i'm
not sure we've ever
looked into that directly but i imagine
in comparison to
the overarching consumer data privacy
concerns
that's sort of lower on on our list of
priorities
but it certainly does have i mean
at a large enough scale removing any
amount of data from an
individual log um obviously does have an
effect in storage costs and and
processing time
okay so that can possibly at some point
in time
especially um with gdpr one could
imagine that storing data and keeping it
around
it's going to be more and more expensive
in the future one can imagine so
that might also be another thing to keep
in mind as you're having these sort of
ethical discussions with your team at
some point
uh back in the old days everyone was
like a cookie monster to get all the
data and we'll figure out later what to
do with it
and i can imagine now that the negative
aspects of that are becoming more
apparent and therefore also more costly
right and i think that's the exact sort
of phrasing that can
help bridge that gap between tech and
business it's not just
that this data isn't useful or this data
is
not privacy preserving this data is
costly
this you can take these concepts that we
have and phrase them in ways that
business people can understand better
and engage in a conversation to help
move them
more towards a privacy driven future
yeah
and risk also definitely makes a return
here as well yeah yes
certainly true cool so like as far as
timing goes that was the first major
theme that we had
and it's also halfway so that's
definitely nice but we had a different
second question that we figured would be
nice to discuss
why is it important to have data first
people working on these problems
because and this also is part of your
introduction because you have a
technical background as well
uh i i don't know what you did in
college but i'm assuming it wasn't just
philosophy so to say
uh it's not even a little no but like
you you came from the i would argue more
technical spectrum and then moved into
this direction
um and i can definitely imagine that you
have an opinion on why you bring
something to the table that's useful in
this discussion
yes i mean so obviously with with gdpr
in in california there's a there's a
consumer privacy
law also called the ccpa um that's on
the state level
a lot of these are written from the
perspective
of lawyers and policy people they
can have a lot of good intentions but
they might not necessarily understand
how things work
from the ground up right there are
sections of the gdpr for example that
allow
major tech companies to self-classify
whether they're a controller or
processor as opposed to a regulatory
committee being able to say
we think you're this that means you're
you are
right these kinds of
uh i wouldn't go so far as to call them
loopholes but these kinds of
slight misunderstandings between policy
makers
and tech companies can lead to
massive uh
massive differences in how the laws are
actually enforced
and how companies react to them as
opposed to what the policy makers
think the reaction will be so it's
important
that when you have
privacy initiatives that you do get sort
of this full
group across across your business if
possible
to be looking at it because everyone can
bring a slightly different perspective
on how something works right
we have for example the new york times a
wonderful lawyer who works with us
internally
who is as good on data questions in
terms of
how the laws are structured how they
might affect our business
but every once in a while you have to
sit down and say okay this is how a data
science model is
constructed in general right there are
questions
um that i'll i'll answer
in a meeting with legal and they'll say
okay is this something we could like
publish in a blog post or this like
this like a secret that we don't want to
tell anyone like this is the first
chapter
of a textbook in your 101 computer
science class
and it's not that they are not smart
it's not that they don't
know what in the world they're talking
about it's just they haven't been
looking in this direction for their
whole lives they haven't
this isn't their main focus so being
able to bring that
different information to them is
very helpful and can bring a lot of
clarity to a conversation
would i be correct in saying that
something similar happens with i suppose
a security professional like you can be
let's say a data scientist but then you
probably in your team depending on what
you do
you'd still like to have something of a
security specialist around just to make
sure that your data is handled correctly
is it a fair comparison yeah i mean i
think in
in terms of this is obviously something
that's much easier to do
in in a large organization like ours but
being able to have as varied a team
as possible allows you to look at any
single problem from different
perspectives right
even if everyone has ended up as a data
scientist right
having a data scientist who came from an
academic background or having a data
scientist who came from an infosec
background or at the
scientific data analysis or the data
scientist who used to be a school
teacher and just taught themselves data
science
all of these people can bring really
different perspectives and i think that
just applies
broadly across any endeavor so
so having data people move into the
policy space
and be able to bring fresh perspectives
to what can sometimes be seen as a
relatively stilted
and stale environment and sort of uh
very legal talk and arcane
details it's good to be able to bring
that in and and help
clarify questions in a different way so
one thing i wonder do you think that
there's a recruitment problem in that
sense in this space
uh because i can imagine if you're a
lawyer then you know if there's a lot of
movement in the laws happening that
you're naturally attracted to that i
suppose because
you know some sense you could argue it's
innovation um
and i i think i also have to admit that
i definitely know more data scientists
who want to keep on doing the algorithm
stuff and then move into policy in that
sense
so would you agree is there a
recruitment problem maybe here or would
you use different words
i would disagree with calling it a
recruitment problem
i think there's an awareness problem
it's it's
something that and you know i don't even
think i'd go as far as calling it a
problem
we have something that is
expanding more and more people's
understanding of privacy on in the
digital age is expanding more and more
we have more comprehensive texts about
this if you look at
relatively recently uh published books
about
for example the age of surveillance
capital by shoshan azuboff right these
are books that are
new and extremely comprehensive
that three years ago didn't exist this
singular
text that defines why data tracking
is so pervasive why how it affects
everyday users
and why we should be concerned right
i did not know about these issues myself
three years ago i can't say that i've
always wanted to be in data governance
i've always wanted to do policy
these are things that happen naturally
when people are exposed
to more information about it when
they're made aware of a problem
uh they can feel that they can help
solve that problem
and i think one of the things that i've
seen a lot out of the data analytics in
the data science world and
admittedly this is with some uh
some bias because that's where i come
from
it's full of people that are interested
in solving difficult problems
at its core right the the tool they're
using now is
python or r or lisp or pearl or whatever
in the world they want to be using right
but but at the base of it a lot of
programmers are interested in solving
hard difficult to untangle problems
and data governance is full of those i
can assure you
so i think especially what we've seen
within the times is we have a lot of
people
that want to work with data governance
from their specific teams and if there's
a spot that opens up on the team they
want to join it that's what happened
with me
i worked with data governance on the
analysis of
the gdpr's effect on our advertising
business and the analysis of
how ccpa might affect our business but
with each step i wanted to go well now i
want to you know move over there if
there's a possibility to right so
it's one of those things where if you
can expose more people to
ethical thinking through whatever means
i think that
a lot of data scientists would be
interested in this kind of work
the i can imagine that i can certainly
imagine how
for an organization like the new york
times it is relatively
it's hard for me to judge of course but
it's but it sounds easier to get started
with this because i can definitely
imagine as an organization there's
there's a need to also have expertise in
this and as you said it's a relatively
larger organization
so it's a little bit easier to find
people of different expertises to come
together and work on a project
would you have any advice for companies
that are perhaps a bit smaller let's say
there's a data team and there's three
people in it
yes that's everyone that's something
we've run into
quite a bit and we we try to talk a lot
with uh you know we're members of
different
uh publishing organizations or we'll
join the w3c for conversations and you
do run into a lot of companies that
are interested they want to do this kind
of work they're they're on board
mentally but their resources aren't that
high and i
won't sort of name names on companies
but there are
for example there's one where um
a publishing organization very
important especially in the united
states has won some of the most
prestigious awards throughout its long
history
um they have two lawyers
right yeah that's a bottleneck
right and and that's not even getting
into the the data science team where
like lawyers are are something that is
well known that uh that uh
the newspaper will need just on first
amendment questions alone right so
um so so there is certainly
a lot of this going around where people
are interested in
in getting involved in getting that work
uh started but don't know where to start
and don't have necessarily the resources
to start themselves
one of the things we try to do as a
larger organization
is have these sorts of conversations
about here's our general thought process
here's how we
work on these questions we can't give
you all the details and we certainly
don't intend on telling you what to do
but here's how we approach these
problems here's how we think of them
and a lot of the times when it comes to
smaller teams a lot of that can just
fall to individuals who want to take it
on themselves
it's it's an unfortunate truth that that
work doesn't always get recognized by by
management or by whoever in the startup
or if it's not a start-up but some
people might
i can imagine that some people sort of
hear the call i suppose and that's
that's what we're sort of going towards
right exactly so you can
take on yourself just starting those
kinds of conversations right
whether it's in your own personal
modeling practices
if you are going through and making sure
that at every step
you feel comfortable with how you're
treating users and their privacy
and if someone says to you hey go
scrape you know facebook and get
everyone's data you go
well maybe i don't want to do that let's
have a conversation about it
those those are relatively easy steps
that any individual can take on
and i think it's in a similar way the
more that an
individual can make their company aware
of ethical questions
and concerns people generally are not
blind to them once once they're
they're put in in front of them it's
just sometimes people don't think about
them
it's so so an easy way to get started is
just get
i don't started if i'm phrasing it the
right way but yeah
it's it's that classic line at the
beginning of all that begating something
begun
right yeah like it takes an individual
at some stages
and for us for the new york times that
happened when
two and a half years ago the head of our
team was hired
he you know obviously a higher up made
the decision that we need to hire
someone for this purpose
and that was brought on by the gdpr
coming coming
into uh effect and us trying to get
ahead of it
they got the ball rolling and then yeah
yeah but then
he hired someone from one part of the
company to to work for him and then they
worked with another person they said oh
that person's pretty good at this let's
bring them on to our team and slowly
expanding and slowly
proving out how useful the team is that
it's not
a cost to the company that it's actually
useful to be thinking about ethics
and useful to try to make yourselves
better
as a company cool so
we don't have too much time left but i
think we can uh
leave on a couple short ones so
i can imagine that there are people
right now listening who are interested
and maybe want to learn more and i also
see some questions coming in
you mentioned the book just before could
you what was the name of the book again
on the
so it's called the age of surveillance
capital
by shoshana zubov
it's really an excellent book um
talking about surveillance capitalism
and how it affects our day-to-day lives
if someone wants a little bit more of a
technical text
that talks about how you can do better
in your modeling practices i would
suggest a book called
bit by bit by matthew solgonic
who is at princeton university and does
quite a lot of research around um
sociologically how do we make sure that
our
modern practices for research and
especially academic research
are ethical and don't affect the users
that we are
running experiments on um so those two
books i think are
excellent uh for anyone that's
interested in the subject
cool wow books are always good for
personal
inspiration in that sense so that advice
is definitely uh welcome
um so thanks this was uh like a little
short
interview talk in that sense that was
also and virtual so we're doing like
multiple things for the first time
uh max thanks a whole bunch will you
also be on the discord forum do you have
access to that
yes i'll be on the discord anyone that
has any questions please feel free to
reach out either in the
uh in the talk chat or personally if you
have
questions that you like to keep private
um
vincent thank you so much for having me
uh i was gonna find my data amsterdam
but i'm glad
that this is uh happening happy to
to to sort of have you here so that
camera
okay
you